salut c'est une figure eu tout juste
rentré de madrid profité y en a pris
l'avion et rentrer chez moi si vous avez
suivi les épisodes précédents des super
voyage super hôtel à vous en ai parlé
dans l'épisode précédent
hélas aujourd'hui vous parler de tout
autre chose on a parlé de survie pendant
quelques jours maintenant on va parler
de microsoft microsoft devrait sortir
une nouvelle console à loeb 2020 une
console dédiée au cloud gaming une xbox
cloud gaming plutôt bonne nouvelle alors
je vais vous expliquer un petit peu
comment devrais peut-être cette console
qu'est-ce qu'elle devrait lui permettre
de faire que toutes les infos qu'on a pu
glaner à droite à gauche dessus et là on
y va
avant toute chose c'est l'été je sais
pas si vous avez suivi je bosse pour
refaire un peu le studio pour qu'ils
soient plus cool un peu plus intéressant
je bosse pour un format améliorer revu
et corrigé à partir du mois de septembre
et là c'est le bordel sans nom dans le
studio
je vous montre un peu les coulisses un
comme ça vous allez voir un peu
l'évolution je sais pas si vous avez vu
vibrations ça c'est le studio tel que
vous le connaissez le décor un petit peu
classique des sauf que là j'ai rapatrier
tous les produits que géante est à faire
ou que je testais tout le truc qui
m'intéresse donc je vais vous montrer sa
grande nouveauté nous avons intégré pour
l'année prochaine pour la saison
prochaine un tableau c'est à dire que je
vais pouvoir vous écrirez choses
directement sur le mur se mettre plus un
pass permettra d'illustrer davantage les
vidéos je n'ai pas encore testé c'est le
premier test on est les bêta testeurs du
tableau alors le mur est un petit peu
régulier avec le bordel
donc aujourd'hui on va parler de cloud
gaming c'est un peu le stress là parce
que je me suis fait chier passé trois
couches si ça craint c'est leur mauvaise
on parle de où ça marche
claude et en plus je peux écrire très
très gros le point un peu négatif c'est
que j'ai toujours une écriture horrible
donc sans pain ni faire bon effet une
chaleur bon là je vais vous montrer un
petit peu tout ce que j'ai ici parce que
je pense que ça peut vous intéresser
c'est un peu ce qui va arriver en termes
de tests vidéo à regarder la chose que
j'ai déjà testé comme par exemple le but
de pro 2 811 m d'un côté ça c'est du
déjà vu
on a déjà testé aussi les coque speck
donc ça c'est pareil c'est déjà vu les
fausses
les coques solide suite de rhinau sheed
ça on a déjà fait également par contre
ce qu'on n'a pas fait et ce qui va
arriver la semaine prochaine c'est
amazon est comme ça on va en parler très
prochainement
plutôt cool pour la déjà un peu prise en
main mais on n'a pas vraiment fait le
tour complet de ce produit on va faire
une vraie vidéo dessus c'est le hanafite
parrot et vous avez dans des coins super
beau d'ici quelques jours dont je vous
invite à vous restez connecté à vous
abonner parce que je vous aurais dans un
spot complètement dingue pour tester un
drone peut pas faire le bon sens on a
déjà testé c'est le au nord 10 à la
stratos de misfits en a déjà testé le
jeune fan 5 lite on a déjà testé
mx2 est ce qu'on l'a déjà testé ça je
vais le recevoir on va lui ouvrir tout à
l'heure pareil ça c'est arrivé ya pas
longtemps on va l'ouvrir
tout à l'heure comme ça on va regarder
un peu les tests qui vont venir bon là
il ya un peu des cartons je sais plus ce
qu'il y avait dedans ça c'est quoi ça
c'est à huy un concours d'ici quelques
jours un test qui va être cool
smartphone horizon de écho ça rester
connecté parce que c'est quelque chose
rien à voir un gagné donc plutôt une
bonne nouvelle
côté tests on va aussi avoir du casque
gaming on va avoir du rhino chine on va
tester aussi une optique qui nous vient
tout droit de californie 200 marques
pour iphone dit ça c'est plutôt cool ça
on a déjà vu ça je les récupère et
avant-hier à madrid donc ça va être cool
on va tester puisqu'elle toujours aussi
et labrosse adorent de shlomi qu'on me
tester aussi d'ici quelques jours
voilà un peu pour mon petit bord
d'avions sueur ici je vous dis il ya
encore des travaux à faire le sol et
tout particulièrement dégueulasse on va
pas se mentir on accepte en tout sera
prêt donc normalement ça devrait plutôt
cool
un nouvel habillage de nouvelles photos
une chaîne revue corrigée et améliorée
marié à chaque fois là j'ai une question
à vous poser
si vous vous y connaissez un petit peu
en photo je cherche je cherche une
solution pour ma caméra pour battre
monde était donc j'ai d'un côté ce petit
outil de joby c'est le petit modèle fond
je trouve un peu plus gros avec ce type
d'adaptateur à à brancher sous ma caméra
et j'ai un pied sur 4,8 et poser la
caméra un pied de la marque syrie s y
est unie c'est pas du tout le même type
d'accrochage pour poser la came ce que
je voudrais c'est quelque chose de très
polyvalent j'ai une seule accroche dans
la calme je peux déclic c'est je le
branche sur un autre pied je le branche
son petit tripote que je vais également
faire un truc hyper st peter fluide si
vous avez des pistes vous pouvez tous
marqués aux commentaires et vous en
serai éternellement reconnaissant face à
ses couleurs
bon aujourd'hui on parle de cloud gaming
on parle de microsoft voici vous
intéresser au cloud gaming si vous êtes
un gamer oui ou non si globalement le
cloud gaming c'est un truc qui peut vous
tentez ou alors vous devrez complètement
moi d'ailleurs si vous êtes tentés ou si
vous jouez déjà en place gagnée
toussaint directement en bas dans la
section commentaire alors microsoft
pourrait sortir une nouvelle console
sera pas réellement une nouvelle console
est plutôt deux nouvelles consoles à
l'horizon 2020 chose plutôt cool
plutôt une bonne nouvelle y aurait donc
une xbox un petit peu plus
traditionnelle pour les personnes qui
souhaitent pas jouer en ligne qui n'ont
pas forcément de connexion internet ou
qui ont collectionné relativement pourri
lapointe coup vous aurez votre console
que vous achèteriez vous jeu dans le
commerce traditionnel
ça c'est la console un peu tradis à
saint-côme xbox one-x encore pu booster
encore plus performante avec lequel vous
pourriez faire encore plus de choses ça
ses premiers points n'a rien d'innovant
cole est déjà le deuxième point sur les
consoles 100% dédié club gaming c'est à
dire une console complètement
dématérialisé en fait vous achèteriez un
espèce de petit boîtier un petit peu
comme le shadow de blade jadot c'est
simplement le premier pc haut de gamme
qui est entièrement dans lequel vous
aurez donc un boîtier qui vous
permettrait de vous connecter à internet
vous auriez vos manettes ils vont
changer tout ça en hdmi sur notre télé
la différence est que la puissance ou
trouverait pas dans votre boîtier la
puissance aurait sauté côté serveur chez
microsoft donc contre un abonnement par
mois vous aurez accès à un catalogue
vous pourriez jouer à plein de jeu alors
je sais pas qui est manière ça pourrait
décliner
est ce qui vous ferait payer petite
partie de ce que vous paieriez un
abonnement global l'abonnement global
100 gagne globalement beaucoup plus de
sens
les points positifs c'est déjà un grand
catalogue de jeux vous n'allez pas à
payer normalement à chaque fois pour
avoir accès un d'ittre vous avez un
abonnement et vous jouer à tous les jeux
que vous voulez deuxième point positif
microsoft garderai toujours son matériel
à jour sert des curés une nouvelle
config beaucoup plus puissante
il la mettra jour pour mir s'est
complètement transparent vous paieriez
votre abonnement vous aurez toujours
accès à une machine hyper puissante
par contre effectivement il faut une
bonne connexion internet ça c'est le
premier point négatif
forcément il faut une très bonne
connexion internet si vous n'avez pas
profité d'une meilleur affichage ça n'a
pas la guerre
vous allez perdre un petit peu en
qualité d'affichage comme sur netflix ou
sur youtube
a contrario si vous allez de la fibre et
vous avez énormément d
vraiment profiter d'une qualité
complètement mal deuxième point négatif
et pas des moindres le jour vous arrêtez
de payer votre abonnement vous n'avez
plus rien vous n'êtes pas propriétaire
d'une console vous n'êtes pas
propriétaire des jeux vous des
propriétaires globalement de rien je
pense même que le boîtier vous auriez
vous devriez le renvoyer comme comme
d'abonnement avec une box ou des choses
comme ça c'est à dire que vous auriez
payé pendant des mois on peut imaginer
chez pas à l'image une fois l'abonnement
à 20 euros par mois jeudi complètement
ça au hasard vous regarder pendant un an
vous êtes déjà à 240 euros vous garder
pendant deux ans vous êtes à 480 euros
et si vous gardez pendant quatre cinq
six ans vous avez payé plus de 1000
euros et au final rien ne vous
appartient ça c'est quand même le point
négatif après ça vous permet de profiter
d'un grand catalogue de jeux tout et si
vous aviez une console physique que vous
avez acheté vous auriez dû acheter vos
jeux c'est pour aussi vous coûter très
cher bon il faut faire des choix
c'est une info qui nous vient du site
américain slate.com sera aux pilotes 100
mais j'ai travaillé un peu mon accent
quand même un microsoft a confirmé à le
3 2018 qui travaille effectivement sur
un service de cloud gaming donc ça on le
savait déjà depuis quelques temps on y
voit un peu plus clair et puis le nom de
code de cette console se serait ce qu'à
rect scarlett claude scarlett cloud
gaming sais pas trop scarlett
voilà un peu pour toutes les infos qu'on
a aujourd'hui sur ce projet de microsoft
ne sais pas si ça peut vous intéresser
si vous êtes gamer est ce qu'un produit
comme celui là pourrait vous tentez vous
marquez tout ça en commentaire et puis
là vous allez voir j'ai un petit truc
pour vous si vous avez une crosse offre
un produit qu'on va tester les
breuilletois
nous allons tester d'ici quelques jours
elle la surface pro et comme une bonne
nouvelle n'arrive jamais seule le au nom
de flight des tests des infos des
concours des actus de tous les côtés
bien évidemment leur au milieu deux sens
à partir en vacances je vais vous
emmener un petit peu avec moi parce que
c'est bien sarah toussaint mais je suis
quand même un petit peu aller se faire
dorer est la rondelle pour être prêt
pour être beau pour être frais pour le
mod 70 pour attaquer à l'ifa est
forcément je vais vous emmener avec moi
à l'ifa à berlin on va les voir un peu
toutes les nouveautés on va les prendre
en main le galaxy note 9 on va les voir
un peu ce qui se passe du côté de chez
au nord quand ailleurs des nouveautés
prévoir ces nouveautés du côté de chez
sony devrait y avoir beaucoup de choses
on va aller voir asus on va les voir
enfin les vallées warwick ont valu par
tout le monde on va aller faire un grand
pour complet un nouveau format des
choses à améliorer un studio qui va
continuer à prendre un peu de gueule
lorsque l'asse encore un peu le bazar
les choses se mettent en place et à
petit donc merci à vous ld toujours plus
nombreuse toujours plus nombreux sur la
chaîne vous invite toujours à partager à
l'essai des jolies poussé puis elle nous
a volé parce qu'ils allaient voir il va
y avoir toujours plus de trucs
merci un soyez ça je veux marquer toutes
vos questions en suggestion directement
vos commentaires ils pensent à moi pour
cette question de petits pieds parce que
j'ai besoin d'être à jour où j'ai besoin
de votre aide vous marrer tout ça merci
portez vous bien vous à eilat
[Musique]